joe biden the democrats never let a
crisis go to waste so this weekend he
used the destruction of the storms as an
opportunity to push his climate agenda
the intensity of the weather across the
board
has some impact as a consequence of the
warming of the planet and the climate
change the specific impact on these
specific storms i can't say at this
point i'm going to be asking the epa and
others to take a look at that but the
fact is that
we all know everything is more intense
when the climate is warming everything
joining me now to react douglas murray
the author of
madness of the crowds in a way douglas i
guess democrats have been honest about
their philosophy never let a crisis go
to waste whether or not that's a mass
shooting you stand on the graves of
children and push for gun control a
pandemic you push your policies a
tornado you push for climate change
policies
you know i can save uh president biden
the effort of having to ask any of the
so-called experts on this
uh there is
abundant evidence that there has been no
change in the frequency of tornadoes in
the united states of america in recent
decades
that's not my view that's a view of for
instance the economist magazine that
wrote this only recently the economist
is not a far-right publication it's a
center-left publication
it was clear about that because the data
shows that there is no significant
increase no change in the number of
tornadoes that have affected the united
states in recent decades i'll give you
another stat that again the democrats
never never want to dwell on this
because
they've forgotten that there were have
always sadly throughout human history
being what we used to call natural
disasters uh natural disasters now are
used by democrats and people on on the
climate left in particular as just
another opportunity to push a particular
political ideology there has for
instance been no
there's actually been a reduction
since 1900 in the number of hurricanes
that make landfall in the u.s a
reduction since 1900 when was the last
time
anyone heard that from a democrat or
official all it is so we always hear
remorselessly whether it's a fire uh
whether it's a hurricane a tornado all
we hear remorselessly is this is why
we've got to do more on climate change
you know douglas and by the way the
president really wasn't even the worst
offender of this just take a look at a
quick tweet by celebrity mark ruffalo he
said this is what climate catastrophe
looks like it's only going to get worse
from here now is the time to fight for
our suffering and despairing youth you
know you know douglas i i look at this
your book by the way is madness of the
crowds and and crowds can go mad but
most definitely when they're driven to
panic and fear by their would-be leaders
and pandemic and and and gun violence
and and and climate change how does a
crowd not go mad when fed this kind of
fear that's right
well
look at that tweet you just you just
quoted our despairing youth
why would youth in america be despairing
what have they got to despair about i
mean compared to any generation in
american history before this one they've
got less than anyone to despair about uh
if there are despairing youth and we
discussed this before the stats show
that significant slaves of american
young people are indeed in a kind of
panic because they've been told by the
by the adults to panic they've been told
they're all going to burn to death or
get blown away this has to be addressed
you can't have despairing youth you've
got to get the facts to the young
douglas murray always wise thank you so
much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else